now another look at global trade policy
author lori wallach looks at the
creation of the world trade organization
and the trade agreements it enforces
this program is an hour ten minutes
welcome to the second event in the event
series for the Everett public service
internship program my name is Amanda
chairs odd and I'm the National
Coordinator I've been working with the
program for two years although this
program has been around for 16 years now
and it's an amazing program working with
200 interns at 60 organizations in New
York and DC we're really excited to have
a speaker with us today her name is lori
wallach and she's a director of public
citizen's global trade watch Public
Citizen was founded in nineteen seventy
one and is a nonprofit research lobbying
and litigation organization based in
Washington DC global trade watch is the
newest of public citizens five divisions
it was launched by mrs. Wallach in 1995
and global trade watch is a leader in
the global citizen movement for fair
trade and investment policy over the
course of the past decade Wallach has
helped create a new public awareness
around globalization the emerging issue
of our time working closely with NGOs
scholars and activists in developing
countries and with us congressional
environment environmental labor and a
lot other allies Wallach has played an
important role in the growing debate
about the implications of different
models of globalization's on jobs
livelihoods and wages the environment
public health and safety and
dramatically accountable governance
please help me and welcome you Lori
Wallach
for the short of stature so it's great
to be here thank you all for coming and
many kudos to the Everett internship
program generally not just for having
the great opportunity for internships in
the public interest but for saying up
these programs where you get to actually
hear a variety of interesting
presentations and speakers and thanks to
NPR for hosting you guys it's kind of
cool to be in this building because a
lot of you at home have heard national
public radio shows and so here's the
mothership um Public Citizen as you
heard described is a diverse
organization we were founded by Ralph
Nader who then promptly in 1981 left us
as he does when he found something in
its on its own feet he served as the
fatherhood thing you are the house i'm
off to something else so in starting an
81 we had new president different people
on the board and global trade watches
the newest Division of Public Citizen
and the one thing I want to say before I
start talking about the WTO and
globalization is just to give the two
second pitch for careers in the public
interest and because you all are in this
internship program you already are hip
to the notion that a person can actually
have a career a job doing stuff you
really care about that makes a
difference but to some degree anyway
when I was in college I think that was a
piece of information a lot of people
really weren't that hip to that you
actually get paid for doing something
you loved that was going to make a
difference and so for all of you just to
keep mine when you get done with school
the notion of actually coming back to
the public interest world but spreading
the word because when I got our law
school the sort of notion was you went
to a firm and if it hadn't been for
actually hearing Ralph Nader's speak
about how you could actually have a job
working on the things you care about I
mean every day I go to work and I love
what I'm doing and yeah you don't get
paid as much as if you're in the private
sector but the bottom line is you can
make living wage and you're going to
love what you do and it's what you can
spend most of your time doing so my
buddies from law school who make a lot
of money and work for vacation they get
the
months a year that they really enjoy but
if you take a career in the public
interest and every day you get to walk
out the house and say all right today's
damn it kick some ass what's on the
agenda for today it really is worth
spending that piece of your life that's
such a big piece of your life you work
life in something you really love so the
two second version of that and sorry for
sounding so nasal as I've picked up a
cold and now onto the very small topic
not of globalization the world trade
organization etc so public citizen is
based in a concept that Nader came up
with of the public citizen in the idea
that everyone as well as their day job
should have a job a role as an active
participant in the life of their
community and in the governance of their
community their state their country and
the public citizen is such a person but
of course it's obvious when people are
really busy doing their day-to-day stuff
it sometimes it's hard to get the
information you need to be able to do
that effectively so the idea of the
organization public citizen was
basically to sort of be the people's
lobby to snoop out the information to
track policies over the long term see
how they worked and then to make the
information a person needs to engage in
the life of their community accessible
so a people can make informed decisions
but then be they have the tools they
need to participate so now everyone can
serve figure out when is Congress in
session and when is that vote on the
issue I care about but we can make the
information available and so global
trade watch was the extension of that
philosophy of empowering individuals
around the country to be able to be
involved it was the translation of that
into the era of globalization and a lot
of people say well did you guys get into
the trade issues no we did not in fact
the so-called trade issues globalization
started to touch on and in fact start to
undermine the 30-year agenda of a
consumer group like Public Citizen so we
were seeing a tax and environmental laws
and food safety laws and we're seeing
medicine prices going up linked to trade
agreements
so we we started getting involved
basically because things we cared about
were being undermined in work we had
done over decades was being rolled back
and the the most recent element of our
work to try and help people be public
citizens is our new book on the WTO
called whose trade organization and the
idea with this book basically was to
take something the WTO the World Trade
Organization agreement that's very
complicated and complex intentionally
written in a foreign language I jokingly
call Gatti's because one of the
agreements and there's the old gap the
general agreement on tariffs and trade
and to basically unless you have a fair
fluency with Gatti's you can read line
of the WTO text and a lot of its
opinions and it may not really be
understandable so our job basically was
to translate from Gatti's into your life
what the World Trade Organization was
about and the reason we did that to give
a little context before talking a little
bit what we found is because WTO is one
of the key instruments of a broader
phenomenon globalization everyone hears
that word kicked around what does
globalisation mean it means a lot of
different things but the current version
of globalization would probably be best
described as corporate globalization and
it is comprised of a specific set of
policies that have been implemented
through different instruments that are
connecting the world and creating rules
of order for the world according to one
set of interests and rules now a lot of
people here globalization it's
inevitable there's actually nothing
about globalization that is for instance
related to the moon's pull on the tides
that in gravity inevitable current terms
of globalization just one version one
political choice there's the old saying
anyone who's working in the policy areas
heard he or she who
writes the rules rules and in this
instance our current instruments of
globalization the world trade
organization WTO which is global
regional agreements like the north
american free trade agreement nafta
finance institutions like the
International Monetary Fund the IMF or
the World Bank these are sets of rules
with international enforcement that have
been set by one set of authors now I
suspect if I was at the table and a
handful of you who care about human
rights labor rights the environment food
security developments we were all
sitting down writing the rules we'd have
a rather different set of rules because
the thing that folks need to know and
this is one of the things we found in
their book this is the World Trade
Organization agreement so people think
you know it's some inevitable thing
maybe maybe Moses actually slept at down
Mount Sinai direct from God I mean it
could be like that but no in fact it's
900 pages of rules and regulations
written by whom well ostensibly by
countries trade negotiators but in fact
as our research found and we have this
all documented in ye old book with lots
of footnotes at the time the WTO is
being negotiated or its evil smaller
sister NAFTA the North American Free
Trade Agreement 800 more pages of
specific rules and regulations nothing
inevitable here my book would be very
different when these two were being
negotiated the US had is official
advisers 500 corporate advisers some of
them nine from us corporations organized
by sectors so there's the chemicals one
the wood one now when you're trying to
figure out the US trade policy say on
would otherwise known as our forests you
might want to have the environmental
perspective the invasive species
perspective the like clean air
perspective given those trees suck up a
lot pollution but no that committee was
all the forestry paper timber pulp and
building interests and so 500 corporate
advisors with
19 labour advisors and and zero
environmental advisors and zero health
advisors zero folks from human rights
basically it was all those corporations
a handful unions and you wonder why you
got particular set of rules again it's
just one version if it's not working
then it needs to be changed or replaced
and that's why we wrote the book because
we now have a nine year track record of
the actual real life play out of the WTO
and ten years plus of NAFTA so you know
back in 92 93 when these agreements have
been negotiated but they weren't
implemented a lot of people made a lot
of promises lie people made a lot of
predictions and at this point the time
for predictions and promise is over you
just have to cut to the chase and look
at the data and so the idea with the
book which is long but is written
actually was kind of a sense of humor
because the findings were pretty
depressing the idea the book is section
by section to go after each of the
different promises but also for that
matter just to do the most conservative
test which is the status quo ante are
things better or worse than they were
when these really into effect even if
the stuff you're promised doesn't come
to fruition okay the people song it
could have been over selling it as long
as it's like a net neutral then maybe it
doesn't have to be changed and so we
want it section by section and in the
book what we literally did is we broke
it up according to how it affects your
life so we have the chapter and
environment and then we have the chapter
on food safety and then there's what's
happened to the US economy I mean we
break it down what's happening with jobs
wages distribution of jobs what's
happened with the trade balance what
that means for different other
indicators like what are our real wages
why is there growing inequality in the
US of income and what's the trade
element and we have a section in human
rights and an agriculture and we talk
about it's happened in developing
countries because obviously the movement
against more corporate globalization
against expanding the WTO etc is based
in the global south is the based in the
developing countries because they've
gotten the worst of it and we have a
chapter in public health and as I'm
going to describe because of the
findings that we actually revealed we
did two things to make it more
accessible one it all had to pass a
mother test which is to say someone's
mother had to read where those chapters
who had nothing to do with trade or any
other policy issue and have the aha
moment so if we didn't have someone's
mom going aha that's how that worked
then the book wasn't going to cut it the
flip side though is we wanted everyone
once they had the aha moment ie
translated all the technical jargon it
kept it very accurate so we put in 1700
footnotes now the book looks gruesome
thick because the hope back of its
footnotes which you never have to go to
but if you want to actually learn in
detail what the WTO and corporate
globalization has done say for food
safety and you decide you wanna go talk
to you remember a Congress because
you're going to be a public citizen or
you want to educate your uncle or aunt
the skeptic then you've got all the
original sources most from web cited so
you can go back and say auntie it's true
that you pray to the idol of Adam Smith
and David Ricardo the theoreticians of
free trade but I hate to just give you
this footnote let me print out some of
these documents folks love you dearly
but in World Bank data shows the
developing countries who've liberalized
fastest have seen huge income inequality
and their growth rates decline and i'd
like to share with you the 400-page will
Bank study I've now printed out jamming
entire computer but that kind of
information so that when you want to
make the point hey this is what's
happened so you have actually the muscle
to go back and say or to read more about
it if you read it you say I'm skeptical
about that those folks at publicis must
have gotten that wrong you can go back
to the original source and actually read
it and we have the pages pinpointed so
you don't have to read the whole
300-page study to get to the data we're
talking about
and the other thing we did is we made a
little sarcastic because it's a little
depressing so for instance the chapter
on the environment is called the WTO's
environmental impact first gat Zilla
eight flipper because in fact the first
trade case was a case against the US
Marine Mammal Protection Act which is
the law that everyone knows from the
tunas the dolphin safe tuna label and
evelyn's tuna fish can and that
particular US law was ruled to violate
the trade rules now you might say where
does flipper laybourn in my country on
my tuna can in my kitchen have to do
with international trade you think trade
you have vision of boats full of
commodities in the ocean not the flipper
label on the tuna in your kitchen
therein lies one of the great
revelations of this book which is the
contents of the World Trade
organization's rules the contents of the
NAFTA's rules they're only about ten
percent about trade and so the
introduction to this book is actually
it's not really about trade now it's
true that the trade rules and here are
lopsided too i'm going to some
particular examples but what else is in
there is an entire whole agenda that
basically sets parameters for every
signatory country that they have to
conform all their domestic policies to
these other non trade policies now let
me just take one step back for context
from the end of World War two a lot of
folks are probably heard of the Bretton
Woods summit varun was created three
global institutions the International
Monetary Fund the world bank and the gat
the general agreement on tariffs and
trade they had three particular roles
the IMF was not like your current IMF it
was to actually keep the gold standard
the currency exchange in the gold
standard going and to give very
short-term loans to float trade so when
you send out something before the money
comes back so you can finance that float
they would give very short with no
conditions loans to countries the World
Bank which everyone knows now for these
mammoths
bad for the environment projects was
actually set up to reconstruct Europe
and Japan after the bombings of World
War two and they were supposed to go
away the gap the gentleman tariffs and
trade was a trade agreement that was
supposed to say multilateral rules some
very basic ones most favored nation
sometimes called MF n that means any
trades days you give to one trade
partner you have to give to everyone in
that same agreement seems fair national
treatment or non-discrimination what
that means is you can't treat a product
differently for regulation for taxes
according to where it's actually
produced so if you have the three
pesticides prepare rule on your domestic
farmers then the imports have to have
that same treatment you can't make them
20 pesticide rule and keep out imports
according to some other regulatory
mechanism and then there were tariffs
cut and quotas cut it only covered
trading goods so when you see the image
of the ships that was the gap and that
was what we had is the trade system with
rounds of negotiations for 50 years
we're in well about 40 years wherein we
come to the Reagan and Thatcher era so
hey bring up the guy in the context of
his recent funeral where he was roasted
in toasters that is the great leader but
he's also frankly the guy who was behind
the brainstorm of this hoe so-called
neoliberal agenda which is a whole set
of policies would you see embodied in
the current WTO which replaced the GATT
would you see in the current IMF the
current World Bank which is a whole
formula that basically translated the
conservative vision of Reagan of
Thatcher and implemented it now here's
what's very interesting about it it's a
set of policies that in domestic
legislators in numerous countries had
been rejected I mean there's the stuff
we know about this trade liberalisation
okay but there's also investment
liberalization and what that means is
not allowing governments to regulate who
owns land to be able to regulate things
like the zoning it's like all the big
cox fights about the kmart stores in the
walmarts the way that's regulated is
basically a retail service invest or
cannot occupy more than X square feet
it's a regulation of investment but
those kind of regulations under this
neoliberal mindset that would undermine
the efficiency of the markets they had
to be get gotten rid of as well as rules
about who could own what would a service
like the water system be public or
private would that be a municipal non
for profit or that be a for-profit other
some things that you just want to not
have in the private sector for-profit
like schools water or should everything
be for sale and setting up rules to
decide that plus finance liberalization
which has to do with stock markets and
currency making your currency freely
tradable as compare difference since
having rules about how much currency you
can take in or take out and a lot of
developing countries had rules and
currency to avoid things like the asian
financial crisis which folks should note
shortly after implementation of WTO
rules on the finance sector
liberalization a lot of countries who
had no infrastructure regulatory systems
who suddenly were told to liberalize
found themselves having their currencies
rated and they used to have an emergency
brake oh my god our currencies being
rated were shutting down the bank there
will be no exchange until the currency
rate goes back to normal gone so you saw
Thailand Korea lose decades of
development with basically our entire
currency raided and the the value of it
cut in half so imagine you know what
something costs and you go to the bank
and you realize you literally have half
the money you have but the price is
basically the same that's what happened
in all these Asian countries because of
Finance liberalisation also in the
smorgasbord is privatization taking
assets are in the private sector and
putting them into the into from the
public sector into the private sector so
selling things like hospitals trains
schools but also privatizing whether
sometimes called essential services that
aren't always solely in the public
sector such as deregulating things like
energy now privatization and
deregulation are deregulation what
friends
cause the California electricity shut
off so when the US trade negotiators run
around and say everyone ought to
deregulate their energy systems the wise
trade negotiators look at them and say
hmm California hello like we only have
brown outs once about every three months
in our developing country city like your
whole place was shut down for three
months why would we want to do that but
that is part of the package as part of
the push and there are new protections
view property protections intellectual
property rules so guaranteeing patents
copyrights and also trademarks which is
to say for many developing countries
they don't allow patenting of certain
things like medicine or seeds a lot of
countries don't allow patenting of
things like life forms or human cells
for moral or ethical reasons but under
this package of policies this is one of
the policies everyone's supposed to
adopt plus harmonization whatever is
left of your regulatory standards that
haven't been deregulated you're supposed
to make to one universal global standard
so there's one standard for what is
considered safe for pesticide
contamination and you can imagine when
you have a global standard you end up if
neither to a a least common denominator
a lower common denominator so you hear
all this stuff and you say right but
what is this have to do with my country
the way it works with WTO and NAFTA when
the country signs on they must conform
all of their domestic laws to the rules
on all these diverse things that have
nothing to do with trade like what does
well how your local school or hospital
works have to do is trade it's a local
service regulation issue or what does
intellectual property patenting of
medicines in Africa that shoots up the
price of AIDS treatments how to do with
trade no one's actually moving the drugs
across the border the question is what
does the patent law have to be within
the country and within its domestic
operations or for that matter what
exactly should be the role of
one-size-fits-all rules on a whole set
of value judgments the biggest
transformation into global
corporate rule through agreements like
the World Trade Organization was the
shift from the objective for instance
the GATT just treat everyone the same to
the subjective the how much pollution
are you allowed to stop the how much
poisons must be accepting your food or
the priorities you set will you make
access to medicines for everyone in your
poor country a priority or you make
patenting a priority making those value
decisions is what transformation Lee
instruments like the World Trade
Organization and NAFTA got into and this
is the big shift this is the difference
between international trade I etrade
inter between countries and
globalization as in one big homogenous
glob of globalization so there's the
inter national versus there's the
globalization glob and the idea is to
have everything round the world as far
as policy regulatory matters fit within
these rules and in fact the operating
clause in the World Trade Organization
is all countries shall ensure conformity
of all of their laws regulations and
administrative procedures so the best
way this was ever described this is
actually in the who's Trade Organization
book was by a rancher I met in Wyoming I
was trying to describe why the US was in
a big fight over what European meat was
like and why that was sort of ruining
him and he figured they'd have the right
to eat what they wanted as long as they
did the same thing with their farmers
why are we in a big spat with him that
tried to explain what was going on he
said I get this exactly what we're
talking about is a high voltage electric
fence right around the pasture and you
can't get out of that pasture now the
cows can do anything they want in the
pasture they can eat they can roll they
can muck around you just can't bump into
that fence and what you telling me
basically is the WTO is set up set a
high-voltage fence around all of our
national governments our state
governments in our local governments
turn down the juice and Bay
to this item ladies and gentlemen you
have two inches to the right twinges to
the left and if you're not inside this
fence you are going to get zapped but
good so your days of the free roving
democracy of you decide your policies
you're finished you're in the pattern
and that actually is a pretty good
description because as well as having
all of these rules which every country
has to change their laws to meet there's
very strong enforcement now just to give
you one example of the u.s. of these
kind of changes because people going to
maybe it's not that big of a deal here's
just one note 700 different pages of non
trade stuff the u.s. used to have as
patent durations a term of 17 years that
meant when someone discovered a new
medicine they had 17 years of monopoly
once they registered the patent where
they were the only ones who could sell
it so everyone here has heard of motrin
new prune all those different ibuprofen
drugs okay that thing was under patent
they had their 17 years and in those
days each one of those tablets cost as
much as a thing of 40 of them is now was
eight dollars a tablet like when I was a
kid okay was under patent they had the
single or control of who sold it at what
price they could set the price it's like
the AIDS drugs are super expensive it's
cuz one owner of that idea has the
monopoly on their sale and distribution
17 years was the term the u.s.
pharmaceutical industry spent years and
years trying to get that extended to 20
years and you know they just couldn't do
it because between all the consumer
groups never ones granny and Grandpa
that were just like a non-starter right
what do you mean you're going to raise
my prices for three more years well in
comes the World Trade Organization this
is just one of many stories we tell in
this book to make this clear in the
World Trade organization's agreement on
trade-related intellectual property let
me just share a footnote which is
revealed in the book which is whenever
you see the term trade related it's the
indicator that actually that chapter has
nothing to do with trade and it's
actually been caboose tin to the WTO and
so that someone should look at and say
geez the copying place put a wrong
chapters someone else's paper in here
they put the words trade-related before
it so the trade related intellectual
property agreement an agreement of
protection
right supposed to be a free trade
agreement but this is a monopoly
protection saying its patents extends
the term of patenting to 20 years and
every country who signs must conform
their domestic legislation so a couple
of weeks after the WTO vote happens in
Congress you get the EO call from the
senator the congressman who'd spent
months trying to get to understand sir
it's not trade hello not trade trade his
small part everything else is basically
what you congressman think you're in
charge of is about to get handcuffed
away from you they'll often they say did
I miss some legislation that seems I've
gotten noticed that the US patent terms
now extended 20 years and we've worked
with you for 15 years to beat that how
could that be those pharmaceutical
companies make so much money anyway how
they get from 17 to 20 years that's
impossible let me say I'm sir silent
slow-motion coup d'etat can we say the
World Trade Organization agreement has
just made you do that you thought that
you were in charge you thought for
something like that to happen you'd see
it jumping up and down in front of you
but in fact through the back door
something that had been won by consumers
for decades got sacked and that is just
one of literally hundreds of examples
which gets back to the book so I have
all these stories in my head because
I've been paying attention to it for 15
years and I will admit it is true I am a
recovering trade attorney but I'm
recovering from that condition because
now that I work in an activist group we
do really uplifting fun things as
compared to reading extremely large
Thomas by yourself in dark basements but
as a recovering trade attorney I've been
able to go through all of these stories
and learn them and so a lot of people
said to me Laurie you gotta write this
down because whenever you talk to
someone you get to be in a conversation
we get it but no one's call these
stories written down so in our book
we've written down all the stories and
let me just give you another cut on the
issue of enforcing these rules which is
the WTO sets up and NAFTA sets up its
own internal tribunal now all the
existing agreements the environmental
treaties the human rights treaties the
labor rights treaties those are alway
are called can
mentions the countries agree
internationally on the terms but then
every country has to enforce that their
own border so you take the convention on
the International trade in endangered
species sigh these big international
treaty and the environment every country
agrees what's on the endangered species
list internationally but then it gets in
forest country by country there's no
sort of sight ease treaty tribunal so
the u.s. passes the Endangered Species
Act and starts to implement that treaty
at the WTO and NAFTA there are tribunals
in fact they are the only self-enforcing
international agreements so when you
hear a critic of one of these agreements
say it's the only currently really
enforceable world government it's
actually not hyperbole I mean the UN has
all kinds of great policies but it can't
be enforced so what happens at the WTO
is these tribunals which in both NAFTA
and WTO they're set up by three trade
attorneys who come off a list and to get
on the list you have to have worked at
the gap or the WTO or represent your
country there so someone like me who's a
trade attorney who knows all this
jurisprudence until my eyeballs roll I
am not qualified to be on one of these
tribunals you have to have a stake in
your organization so you can imagine you
don't get the most fair judgement when
the people who are the judges of the
people have worked for the institution
as being challenged and they meet in
secret I mean totally in secret as in no
press no public the tribunals are
typically set up in Geneva the WTO's
headquarters and there's a professional
legal staff that does a lot of the work
which means they have a lot of power and
these three panelists with the help of
the secretary act with the WTO's legal
staff are basically empowered to judge
if your domestic law fits within the
constraints up by the WTO and if it
doesn't and they rue it doesn't there's
no outside appeal there is an internal
appeal it's not by that seems to
overturn these cases very often and in
fact the WTO rules are so lopsided that
as we found when we analyzed for the
book all the cases that have come
through the WTO the plaintiff the person
who takes the case challenging a
domestic law has one ninety-five percent
of cases so basically you bring a case
it's almost impossible to save your
domestic law by proving it's inside the
rules and the kinds of laws have gotten
sacked include the US Clean Air Act
regulations and gasoline cleanliness the
u.s. endangered species rules on Dolph
and turtle excluder devices in shrimp
Nats the US Marine Mammal Protection Act
the Korean food long shelf life
regulations there have been a series of
rulings against India that have
basically forced that country to start
patenting seeds life forms etc even
though india the world's largest
democracy had a constitution that
explicitly for bad the patenting of
seeds life forms etc and pharmaceuticals
it's been a series of rulings against
different countries food security
policies ie for the developing countries
who've had it with the rich countries
dumping their subsidized food on them
some of them put up policies to keep the
dumped Goods out but under the WTO rules
the dumping is actually allowed it's not
disciplined and stopping goods at the
border that can be challenged as a
violation of the WTO and on and on and
on go the cases now these tribunals have
the power where they order the country
there to change their law or to face
trade sanctions and so it's basically
amazed to call it a kangaroo court but
our allies from Australia so that was
extremely insulting to marsupials so it
is the worst thing kangaroo court that
has trade sanctions so if you don't
change your domestic law you face
perpetual trade sanctions let me give
you an example because it's only one
case where country has not changed the
law over a long time and face the
sanctions and that's another these
disgusting cases that show how extreme
the rules are and we go in gory detail
through that whole case in the who's
Trade Organization book European
consumer groups find it out with the
pharmaceutical and farm groups to get a
ban on artificial growth hormones in
beef it was a big domestic fight and
they won with referendums so the whole
European Union passes a law that says we
will not allow
now the use in Europe of artificial
growth hormones for raising beef error
or the sale of beef grown with
artificial hormones in Europe which is
to say we don't let you use it here and
make that food and you can't import it
either it's not discriminatory right
under the old ghat rule if treat
everyone the same you're treating
imports and domestic food the same so
what's the trade issue well one of those
WTO tribunals ruled that in fact that
rule violated the WTO food standards
rules because those rules forbid you
from using the so-called precautionary
principle you actually put a ban on
something and make the industry prove
it's safe which by the way is about how
half of us products are regulated like
pharmaceuticals the burden is on the
pharmaceutical country to show they're
safe and efficacious it's not on the
consumer groups of the government to
show they're dangerous the industry has
to do the testing and show it's not
going to hurt you that's normal well
under this particular ruling the ruling
was the burn was on the government to
show that those beef hormones were
conclusively scientifically harmful and
the fact that they had seen some
evidence for instance all those hormones
cause cancer when people directly
consumed them but there hadn't been
long-term studies what happens when you
consume the beef that's consuming the
hormones if you're a human but you
already know the hormones themselves a
human carcinogens should be enough plus
have been various and sundry other
pieces of scientific evidence that
conclusive but enough to worry WTO says
no no acting on precaution you cannot
take the measure and that principle of
precaution is now all the environmental
treaties you can't take the measure to
avoid harm if to prove it's dangerous so
Europe has been paying 150 million
dollars of trade sanctions for the last
five years to keep out our home or her
our home hormone tainted beef yes they
have to pay a ransom not to eat the food
they don't want to eat which they pass
by a referendum which is also applied to
their own domestic farmers sounds crazy
but it gets worse because now with the
WTO's track record so and even what we
found in researching this book is now a
mere threat of a challenge is often
enough to make a country drop a policy
and one of the most gruesome cases has
to do with Guatemala Guatemala had
adopted what's often called the nestles
code I mean you guys probably are too
young to remember this but there was a
huge global boycotted Nestle's in the
late 60s in the early 70s because they
were promoting breastmilk substitutes
baby formulas incredibly aggressively
advertising to illiterate women in
developing countries insinuating that
they'd be healthier their babies would
be healthy or drinking the formula but
of course if you're not in a place where
they're safe water and you mix dirty
water with formula the baby dies of
infant diarrhea and so in fact the UN
and the World Health Organization got
together with the civil society campaign
which was run out of the churches the
World Council of Churches really was the
mover of this whole thing and it was a
fight against an epidemic of needless
child deaths that's how they describe it
that was the World Council of Churches
hardly a radical group so they fought
they fought and they fought and they got
a UN treaty and it had a couple of basic
rules no deceptive labeling so he had
have a plain package like you couldn't
have a picture of like a healthy baby so
you'd have someone who couldn't read say
ooh formula picture of fat baby my baby
skinny I give the formula fat baby you
couldn't have promotion in hospitals so
you couldn't have someone going to woman
who's just delivered and saying here you
should give you baby this just 15 days
later the breast milk is dried up in
there hooked you couldn't have
advertising by health officials you know
just basic consumer rules country after
country Dobbs's treaty Guatemala adopts
it and they become the poster child for
UNICEF because their infant mortality
rate goes way down it's really working
for them at which point the WTO is just
about to be improved at which point and
we're already fighting with consumer
groups around the country about in the
world I did a call from the Guatemalan
Health Minister you know at first I
thought was a joke if that wasn't my
friends we hadn't returned to call to is
trying to like get through to me and you
had someone say it's a Guatemalan Health
Minister calling but it really was the
Guatemalan health minister and he said
yeah I hear you a trade attorney but you
work in a consumer group so you're not
gonna bill me the usual Washington three
hundred dollars an hour to give me a
little advice I have this outrageous
letter from your State Department that's
claiming that are adopting the unicef
baby milk code is a violation of the
world
organization then we have to get rid of
the implementation of the treaty which
is saving babies otherwise we're gonna
take us to the WTO are they like making
this up to intimidate us could you look
at these documents and just give us a
small verbal opinion about whether
they're just trying to spook us and we
should ignore them we actually have to
respond to this I said yes sir send it
send it away so I get the detail packet
and sure enough there's a step 8 State
Department letter their theory is this
Gerber baby foods based in the US has a
trademark on their trademark fat baby
face but under the plain packaging rule
you can't have a depiction of a fat baby
so what they're asking Gerber to do is
conform with the law and just have a
plain packages as Gerber in a blah blah
blah the ingredients and get rid of the
fat baby but in the wto's trade-related
intellectual property rules there's a
guarantee of trademark protection so
this letter literally says our WTO
trademark protection rights Trump this
UN treaty and as a matter of law
whatever treaties later in time there's
a convention on the interpretation of
treaties whatever treaty is later in
time does Trump so they write this
letter it's very intimidating I start
looking through the different parts of
the WTO that would apply and I said well
there's a health exception in the
intellectual property rules but they
probably go and get you in another part
of it I think you should fight it and we
can try and help you get lawyers you
still have to pay some but this is
outrageous and if nothing else we can
make a moral case and so we'll just
embarrass them into not pursuing it well
about three months later I hear back and
you know cost by million dollars to
defend the case of the WTO and so I
heard back from the minister and he said
you know the way you laid it out even if
it was like 60 percent chance for us a
million dollars almost our entire
immunization budget so can we spend a
million dollars gambling that we can
stop a WTO challenge that kills babies
or do we give up the million dollars and
stop humanization which kills babies and
the immunizations a sure thing we've got
a 50-50 chance on this so it breaks our
hearts but we've changed the law I just
want to let you know the u.s. products
don't have to comply anymore and they
don't and so we've tracked the date of
what's happened with infant mortality
etc and all of these documents which
we've actually made it publicly
available are amongst some of the many
that been leaked to us that tell the
stories in this book because so much of
the stuff is secret you can't know and
so there's Guatemala's effective law
there are all these kids the most
vulnerable citizens of a developing very
poor country who gotten squashed by the
WTO and it never even went to a tribunal
so for us part of why this book is so
interesting is people tell us about
these cases because they know we're
trying to track the real-life effects
because the bottom line of how public
system works is you estimate the pros
and cons and then if it's not working
you know it's not inevitable then you
got to change it I mean the one thing
that seems clear about this model of
globalization is as it stands it's not
really survivable so then the question
becomes do we figure out a calm and
reasonable change to some different
rules because we do need global trade
rules we don't need these rules are one
size fits all on everything but we need
rules on trade so when you get the trade
rules right and dump some of this other
baggage that's been put on or you just
wait forever to start ignoring it for
total autarky for the poorest countries
to get into a total state of misery
because of the actual outcomes these
agreements and this gets the final point
before QA which is the economic track
record two of the chapters of the book
are based on the economic track record
and the reason I didn't focus on the
economics but focus in the domestic
policies first is because most people
are more familiar with the economic
fight but a lot of people don't realize
this one size fits all in position
business with the secret tribunal
sacking our laws by the way just FYI in
the u.s. we did weaken the Marine Mammal
Protection Act that dolphin-safe label
doesn't mean that anymore it's back to
the days of chasing the dolphins with
the boats and the circular nuts it only
means that no one observed a dolphin
dying well the nets are the size of ten
football fields so for someone who
observe them when there's only one
observer required in a boat doesn't mean
anything there goes the tuna dolphin
label the Clean Air Act regulations and
gasoline cleanliness were rewritten to
implement something that the EPA the
Environmental Protection Agency had
thrown out it's unenforceable and
useless that would increase carbon
emissions by 5% the Endangered Species
Act rules on turtles were weakened
so that shrimp is now allowed in the
country that doesn't meet the Endangered
Species Act standard just put this in
perspective in the US some of the cases
so what's happened economically in the
u.s. perhaps the most telling statistic
is the following which is one that
certainly affects your guys futures so
everyone gets to hear from the parents
maybe the grandparents how from after
World War Two until the early 70s there
was this great boom for the first time
people were able to buy houses people
didn't have cars got cars and the u.s.
real median wage it's the medium the
middle where the bulk of people are and
the real wage to adjusted for inflation
so not just the fact that the dollars
gotten bumped up at the real wage from
World War two until nineteen seventy two
which was the top of one of the growth
cycles which is served where you measure
these trends it increased eighty-five
percent so mean median real wages in the
u.s. increased eighty-five percent Matt
chunk of time if you now go from 72
until the current time trade is now two
times the share of gross national
product of the US but our real median
wages are flat which is to say it's
basically the same as it was in 1972 and
in fact if you look at certain sectors
of the country actually we haven't
caught up to nineteen seventy-two the
real median wages are lower than they
were in 1972 yet trade is now two times
a gross domestic rock I e trade's a much
bigger share of our economy but our real
wages are very flat now a bunch of
economist have said is there a
connection to that we'd better go figure
that out it's been the economists who
support the NAFTA in the WTO because
they don't read these agreements and
they think they're free trade a theory
that works and then you have a bunch of
economist who are saying very odd what
could be causing this income inequality
to grow so much which by the way the
biggest factor in the median wage being
low is the top is going way up at the
bottom is declining the middle staying
where it is there is an inequality of
distribution of income and for folks who
saw last year the New York Times and
they called it the new era of the robber
barons there has not been a growth in
income inequality in the US and Satori
the century to
we have now it's stark it's shocking and
it's happening by the way with in many
countries and between countries so
between the rich countries in the poor
countries the gap is growing and with in
many many countries within the country
the gap is growing so what's the cause
well interestingly the Institute for
International Economics which is one of
those think tanks is very prone afton
WTO they are analysts a guy named
William Klein and again all of this is
written out carefully with the footnotes
in whose trade organization he estimated
that thirty percent of the increased
income inequality was being caused by
trade liberalisation and by the way the
theory of free trade the old Ricardo
Adam Smith theory it has as a prediction
of the theory that you increase income
inequality so these guys who are the
classical theoreticians of free trade
theory will recognize that's true and
then they want to measure what is that
effect because the way free trade
economics works is the gain is on the
import side it's the general benefit to
consumers of lower prices created by
competition so if you gain and free
trade it's because the price goes down
but you also in the theory might see
wages in certain sectors going down but
the theory holds if the overall gains in
the economy by lowering the weight by
lowering the prices will compensate for
the fact that only some people's wages
will go down and in fact you'll expand
the pie you'll be more efficient so you
actually have more money to put into new
industries everything grows new people
get new jobs and yeah you have to help
the people who are in the losing piece
of it but that the net is always
positive because everyone gets the
consumer benefit and only a few people
get hit in their wages of their job well
an interesting study was done by the
Center for Economic and Policy Research
it's a website i highly recommend
Seaborg and they took the conservative
prone afton WTO economists estimates of
inequality caused by trade and then they
plugged in the real data I'm median
wages you see what they found
interestingly it was that at this point
the way the free-trade economics is
working domestically basically by
readjusting the quality and types of
jobs exist
so it's not that you look just at the
net number oh my god there's a net less
1 million jobs you look at what kind of
jobs and then what those pay and that
shows you where the inequality is and so
they did the study where they applied
the conservative guys estimates mean
equality and they found that this point
the savings on the consumer and the
lower prices is now outweighed for the
median by the loss in income which is to
say using the actual theory you can show
that a huge chunk of the median wage
earners of our country are actually
losing under our current trade
liberalization under the theory using
the conservative guys modeling well
that's a really interesting piece of
research now now I'm no economist so one
of the good things about the book is
it's actually we didn't send Matt
chapter day one's mom I had to
understand that chapter because I had to
write it so we boiled down all the
theory and we go through the whole free
trade theory and apply the real numbers
and the thing that's very interesting is
you can find data that says the
following the US has lost almost 3
million manufacturing jobs in the era of
NAFTA and WTO then I put that in
perspective that's one in six of the
entire sector in 10 years so if you
think about for instance the
industrialization period the turn
century where you went from the Korean
society to an industrial society you
know 50 years in the midst of that huge
strife the creation of the labor
movement federal legislation and you
have the shift we have now one in six
manufacturing jobs gone in ten years
without any particular safety net
reorganization set up as everyone knows
the newest trend now is towards
offshoring not just manufacturing jobs
but service sector jobs high tech jobs
computer jobs engineering jobs even
medical diagnostics and this is all
being done by the way without paying
attention to the existing us regulations
on things like our banking and health
information is protected under domestic
privacy laws but when it gets offshored
in part because of these services rules
of the trade agreements none of those
rules apply overseas so in fact
particular bank was sending information
for processing and they got held
basically
ransom that if you don't pay me more
money I'm going to post this on the
world wide web is I'm working here in
Pakistan your privacy laws don't apply
you're going to be liable though under
your laws so it's worth paying me a
bunch of money so I don't post your
entire database on to the world wide web
and therefore get you sued so you're
going to get sued for three millions
we're playing me X amount now besides
the blackmail just a little worrisome
that you your friends and everyone
else's health status or financial status
or social security numbers your identity
can be stolen should be out and running
about but once again you have a whole
set of issues where government have been
handcuffed about how you want to set of
common-sense regulations although in
that 1 i'm happy to say Congress is
fighting back now the economic seen in
the US has been interesting in the sense
of we've seen a total shift away from
manufacturing but in the developing
world the news has been really gruesome
and that is actually r I'm going to stop
which is the most important economic
fact perhaps to learn if you're not
going to read the whole book pick up the
fact sheets because we have a set of
fact sheets each color is a different
chapter and it summarizes the key
findings and so if you've ever wondered
why in the developing world in India and
Malaysia and Indonesia and Bolivia you
have millions of people on the street
protesting against the WTO the IMF like
when the developing world social
movements saw that we finally had a
protest about the WTO in Seattle in 1999
which Public Citizen had a lot of role
in helping to organize they sent emails
saying well congratulations but it's
about time I mean when they started
passing these things we told you guys
this is your structural adjustment this
is like you guys are about to get what
we've gotten but we've got 30 years of
experience so nice that you finally
gotten with the program and handed darn
protest because we've been fighting this
for 20 years and so in the developing
world why people are out the streets is
the following the price now for good
particularly food agricultural goods
sent from the rich countries into the
poor countries is basically set below
the cost of productions called dumping
and what it means is you have food
basically the WTO agriculture rules
allowed the rich countries to keep their
subsidies it basically frozen going in
place
there's a thing called export subsidies
which is what the grain trading and meat
companies get not the farmers and the
domestic subsidies and there's called
domestic support which is what the
farmers get and both of those got frozen
in place there's a little bit of a
decline but largely frozen in place what
that means though is if you were a poor
country I didn't have any money for
those kind of programs you get frozen
it's zero so even though the rich
countries are frozen at high subsidies
and as a result can sell food into your
market below the cost not only of what
may it cause they're farmers to produce
it but if what caused your farmers ie
they can bankrupt your farmers by having
subsidies you aren't allows developing
country to have a counter subsidy or
what's called quantitative restriction a
quoted try and keep it out those are the
WTO rules and the article in agriculture
actually the chapter in agriculture is
one of the ones that is probably as far
as deciphering the WTO rules one the
most useful because those rules are so
arcane and explains exactly how it is
that right now more people in the
developing world are facing malnutrition
ten years nine and a half years after
WTO than before how it has come to pass
after ten years we were promised that
the WTO would increase global wealth and
increase the wealth of the poorest
countries how more people are living on
one dollar a day now and that's the
World Bank's model for extreme poverty
now you're you hear people come back and
say ah but actually the thing that's
good is the percentage of people living
on one dollar a day has declined a
little bit let me share with you one of
the many economic tricks reveal in the
book which is that number includes China
but ladies and gentlemen China was not a
member of the WTO until the last six
months of the measurement period China
was outside the WTO and in fact China
effectively gave the royal development
raspberry to almost every element of the
WTO they exported a lot but they
subsidize their exports they banned
imports lots of trade restrictions the
currency still is not tradable to
totally control currency so you can
trade the Chinese Ron suck in Thailand
we can crash though currency or Korea
and then buy up the entire manufacture
sector and own it you can't crash the
currency you can't do anything with the
currency less the government says
investment strictly regulated now the
government has the Chinese government
has many many downsides and problems
regarding human rights what they've done
with investments actually is a
development thing really clever because
I basically said okay for an investor
come on in but here's the deal you're
going to make money out of this it needs
to benefit our development so here are
the conditions you can invest here but
then you have to do this set up this
road or we get some part of the
electricity goes to these villages over
here because you're going to set up an
electrical plant those kind of condition
al-azhar invest on investment that
precisely would have forbidden in the
WTO so all this stuff that China did and
had incredibly fast growth rates and
lifted moon's people out of poverty are
exactly the things you can't do if
you're in the WTO which they've just
joined and they're huge fights over
whether or not they'll change all these
domestic policies but if you take China
out of that number you take the total of
China and the growth of China out in
fact there's a huge percentage gain in
one dollar day because all the rest of
the developing world which actually had
to say they had signed up and had to
stay with those rules have seen the
growth decline so for instance if you
look at Latin America you see during the
period that's concerned serve pre
globalization from basically 1952 the
mid 70s you see growth rates per capita
growth rates which again I know growth
is not the best measurement but it's the
one say the world bank uses and it gives
you some sense of how the economy is
doing you see the growth rate there of
seventy two percent that bad then you
see all those countries structurally
adjusted it all sign up to the formula
the IMF does it more than the WTO
because a lot of the Latin American
countries weren't originally the WTO and
then got in but okay they follow the
whole set of formulas what's happened
seven percent per capita income growth
and the period from the 70s up until
2001 which is the most current data
Africa in that first period positive
growth rates thirty two percent second
period all structural adjusted all
following the rules growth rates of
negative twenty-three percent basically
Africa has lost wealth following this
model
and in fact what the data shows is that
no country has developed under the
current rules that are being imposed by
the WTO and the IMF on developing
countries so if you look at why the base
of the movement against corporate
globalization is in the developing
countries it's because they've been
living with the most terrific results
for the past 30 years and with that I
will simply say the good news is there
is a global movement that links northern
and southern civil society and social
movements there's a network called that
our world is not for sale network as a
website with the initials of those words
and it puts together movements from all
over the world to fight for a more fair
set of rules and so the key document
you'll find there that lays out what
were for is called the WTO shrink or
sink statement it's 11 transformational
changes to the WTO that does things like
cut out the stuff that shouldn't be
there like the intellectual property
rules that made Gerber's trademark be
more important babies it cut would have
cut out some other pieces such as the
rules that set priorities so we'd be
back to no discrimination as long as you
treat foreign and domestic the same you
decide how much pesticide you decide
what the priority is you decide as long
as treat people the same and it also
talks about how the food trade could be
regulated to try and increase food
security and I urgent when you go to our
website which is trade watch org where
you can find all of the materials been
talking about links along the footnotes
from the book linked and also links to a
lot of different action opportunities
because they're fair trade campaigns all
across the u.s. and there's going to be
a big congressional fight in the next
six months over an attempted naft
expansion called the Central American
Free Trade Agreement CAFTA rhymes with
NAFTA must be bad news and basically
it's just you know it's NAFTA on
steroids for five more countries it's a
really bad deal if someone asked me a
question about it I will describe why
but I hope if you are persuaded if
you're not read the book and think about
what position you want to take the
globalization issue in these rules are
going to be the defining matter of your
generation so like my parents generation
in some degree that people were little
ol in maize World War two
globalization getting these rules rights
poverty inequality global trend of
disease these are the issues that are
going to find your generation and so
take a position get the facts and then
get in the fray thank you very much we
have time for just a few quick questions
if anyone has any questions there's one
in the back go ahead and stand up talk a
little bit about the calls for including
labor into though details it is an
intravenous to support level Labor
Standards mm-hmm when I hear a couple of
questions and now buzz through the
answers okay other something your
comment it's on me I was hoping you
would comment on the recent WTO ruling
on American cotton subsidies
specifically whether you think the
United States watch they have to change
its domestic policy
um I was curious I went to a
subcommittee hearing a couple months ago
that was on Foreign Relations Committee
in the Senate there's a subcommittee
that discussed NAFTA ten years after its
implementation and only one person of a
panel of six that's critical of NAFTA
I'm just wondering if you could comment
a kind of public accountability and kind
of Congress's role in like looking into
policy okay i'm going to start actually
with that question first which is the
current way we make trade policy is
under this procedure which largely
insulates congress which is when we have
to change its called fast-track it
basically the US Constitution gives
Congress exclusive authority over trade
but the executive branch has exclusive
authority constitutionally talked to
foreign sovereigns so when you want to
set up the actual negotiation you got to
share power and fast track is a
power-sharing I say that consciously set
up by Richard power grab Nixon that
basically takes all the legislative
power and gives it to the president and
under that system basically any trade
legislation gets on something like a
legislative luge run there are no
amendments allowed there's limited
debate there's no normal committee
procedure there aren't even normally
hearings so what ends up happening is
you have members of Congress able to
hide behind that basically say oh woe is
me there's so many things are terrible
about that agreement but I have no
option I can't fix it I must vote yes or
no in the whole thing it would be a
cataclysm to vote no and so basically
you have ninety percent of garbage super
glued to ten percent of reasonable trade
rules and legislative laxative right
through the Congress it becomes new
trade agreement and that system in part
is how these members of Congress duck
and so when they you try and give it a
vote to trick them and vote no they say
oh can't do it now the shift in this is
and this gets to be the answer to
particular you're hearing is in fact at
this point NAFTA nationally polls so
negatively because so many people have
either had someone involved in one of
the food poisoning incidents as if
someone who's lost a job has a relative
in Mexico who's lost their farm you know
someone in Mexico's tried to immigrate
here because I
manufacturing jobs have taken off
because wage has gotten so low one or
another of members of Congress who were
for NAFTA have switched but that
particular hearing the entire because we
were there to the entire agenda except
for one witness was sat by the
Republican majority and given that
President Bush's right now 20 28 NAFTA
expansion it would not be a particularly
save early political moment to reveal
the catastrophes of ten years of NAFTA
so they stacked five people and I mean
they had to dig to find five people who
actually were vaguely reasonable and did
not come from another planet who would
actually cheerlead I'm NAFTA the old
cheerleaders now say oh it's over break
even and the people who are critics say
Lord oh Lord we underestimated so one of
the sets of documents out there is
actually a set of fact sheets on ten
years of NAFTA and you can see those in
our website too and we did the same
thing with you at the book we got all
the data and we footnoted it endlessly
and the bottom line of it is Mexico's
probably lost the worst the US and
Canada have not done well by it you can
show net data that shows basically the
big winners are a handful of companies
in chemicals in auto manufacturing and
in food trade it's like the konig
where's the cargill's those guys the
archer daniels and they've made really
nice profits but real wages are dropping
all the countries etc so the reason why
is so lopsided on the cotton ruling
that's also very political and it's a
real question so just to update people
very quickly there is if there was a
thing in the WTO agreement amongst all
the unfairness ha's there was a rule
that was basically a rule that no
country would challenge each other under
the agriculture rules which is so
lopsided in the first eight years and
then that thing sunset and so Brazil was
the first one to roll out a challenge
and just now the final check the final
ruling actually has happened this Friday
the WTO is ruled that the u.s. subsidy
program on cotton violates the WTO rules
now it's very interesting is if the
cotton program violates WTO rules which
has now been definitively ruled in there
is no outside appeal then about
two-thirds of the u.s. farm program
violates the WTO rules and we don't have
time to talk about the details if you're
interested in farm policy get the book
and look at that chapter they're
basically different categories of how
you categorize subsidies
and the u.s. stuck our subsidy programs
in one box and the WTO basically sent
and you guys are putting in the wrong
box it belongs over here and if it's
over here you can't do it if that's true
then half of our egg programs are in the
wrong box if the u.s. implements it's a
really interesting question because
we're going to come up with a farm bill
fight in not next year but the year
after and so the u.s. theoretically by
an act of Congress is going to have to
amend the farm act to implement which
could be an incredible knock-down
drag-out fight there are sort of two
scenarios there's a scenario that
somehow or another the thing gets
amended into compliance they try and
figure out a different way that is not
WTO legal to pay these cotton guys and
that could still screw the farmers in
Africa and Brazil who are fighting in
these subsidies alternatively the US
could give the royal raspberry to the
WTO and although it is only Europe who
is sat at a WTO ruling for years taking
the sanctions the u.s. is now sneaking
into the line of that category because
there are currently three WTO rulings
the US has lost the US has refused to
implement you might ask why because
there simply is not political support to
do it and so the cases i described
except for the dolphin case the
president could just do it by executive
order the dolphin case took five years
to change that law and had to go through
Congress well for this case for the
cotton rules and for the other three
cases throughout their kongs would have
to act and since it's a small problem
the members of Congress were sold a
total load of bunk they were told this
WTO nothing to do with sovereignty
nothing to do with domestic policies we
can never do whatever the hell we want
at home it just about Erickson quarter's
more of the usual trades they calm don't
listen those people over there and in
fact at the time of the WTO debate Ralph
Nader offered $10,000 the charity of
choice of any US senator who would
simply sign affidavits saying they had
read the WTO which they were about to
vote on you know not tough read it sign
of thing that's it you get ten thousand
dollars and answer five simple questions
really basic ones about what the rules
were what we've waited for four months
we couldn't find a sailor take it and
then you know because we were really
agitating about the WTO they extend the
vote and so one guy steps up he's a
Republican senator from Colorado his
name's Hank Brown had voted for NAFTA
and the
he saw this was this was the day I get
to stick it to Ralph Nader like he was
sure that we were just nuts he was going
to read the thing come back and then
basically publicly humiliate Ralph with
five questions so he goes home over
thanksgiving recess reads WTO and I'm
the person right in the five questions
so browse like you know I can't be
idiotic but don't make him too hard so
he goes to the five questions he gets
him all right I'm like oh my god what
have I done and he then goes up to the
microphone and says and ladies and
gentlemen here today to announce I'm
against the WTO I'm a free trader and
it's a damn good thing I read that thing
it is very little do about trade totally
undemocratic this is a horror I don't
believe it maybe it's like this in NAFTA
there's a whole transcript of him going
aha so what basically is the state of
affairs is you got to have half of the
House and Senate where who didn't read
it who were fed this whole line are
about to have an aha moment and they
gonna announce that basically they have
been replaced by the WTO I mean are they
gonna say hi here are the hands but I'm
handcuffs yes throw away the key hard to
say they're kind of turfy and then the
final issue is labor in the WTO I just I
can't speculate because I think it's
going to be a bloodbath labor in the WTO
so the position that um Public Citizen
takes as well as the global coalition
the network I was not for sale is not to
add Labor Standards to the WTO but that
rather the trade agreement should focus
on trade and that need to be whittled
way back down closer to what gat used to
be and that what you actually need is
checks and balances and global
governance which is to say you need
enforceable labor standards we're for
enforceable labor standards and we are
for enforceable human rights standards
and environmental standards what we
don't think is the way to go though is
to put all that stuff into an agreement
who is going 100 miles an hour in the
opposite direction when you want to
start moving the world this way and so
instead what we want to do basically is
cut back the WTO so there's checks and
balances when there is conflict between
different priorities and it's not the
WTO that gets to decide hmm when there's
a conflict between labor rights and
trade which should take precedent ha
maybe the WTO it's closed tribunal who's
going to get us anyway sorry w
ruin twins when we can't we can't have
that scenario now having said that it is
the case that the ICF to you the
International Confederation of free
trade unions which is the Confederation
of labor Federation's so the afl-cio is
the US Labor Federation and it has 80
plus unions are members so if you hear
the steelworkers the Teamsters those are
the members of that Federation and the
u.s. Federation of Federation's all over
the world so basically the people who
represent organized labor are together
in the ICF to you the Confederation of
Federation's and their position is to
add labor stands to WTO and it's a huge
debate and they're good arguments on
both sides and so how we dealt with that
issue because we have a lot of respect
for our brothers and sisters in the
labor movement what we've done is we
actually is a chapter on labor and human
rights that lays out the whole debate
and it lays out the best arguments for
both sides and it comes up front and
says here's where public citizen stands
but on the other hand the arguments of
the labor unions is yes there are many
rules in WTO that go the opposite way of
labor rights but it's the only fans
enforceable it's a very important point
that is the only enforceable
international government's body the
international labor organization with
international labor rules and
conventions are set is not enforceable
in the same way W to it the tribunals so
they've got a point when they say it's
the only enforceable thing the problem
is from our analysis even though that's
true then we have to figure out some
other way to make them enforceable
because the other downsides but both
arguments are laid out and it's really i
mean it's important to actually hear
both sides of it because it's a current
debate respectful a current thank you
thank you again lori wallach lori
wallach is director of public citizen's
global trade watch she's co-author of
the WTO five years of reasons to resist
corporate globalization and contributed
to alternatives to economic
globalization whose trade organization
is published by new press visit the new
Prince com for more information